ANNOUNCER: Please
welcome David Gelles.
DAVID GELLES: Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
How are you all?
Good?
Good lunch?
We also have Mindful
Work stress balls
over where we're
selling the book, so be
sure to pick one of those up.
Well, thank you all so
much for being here.
It's an honor.
Today is actually the
publish-- pub date for my book.
I see a couple friends
in the audience.
Which is thrilling.
I mean after 2 and
1/2 years, more,
of working on this, to actually
have this thing in the wild
is pretty extraordinary.
And so I'm thrilled
to be here on pub day.
Before I prattle on
about mindfulness,
for a few minutes-- and
we'll have plenty of time
to talk and questions--
I wonder if I
might draw you all in to
this practice, whatever
this mindfulness thing is
that we're talking about
and actually just make us sit.
We're going to practice
mindfulness just
for a minute or so.
So if I may ask, if you could
shut your laptop screens,
if you could put your phones
away just for a minute here,
I promise it won't
take too long.
And for those who haven't
practiced mindfulness before,
here's what we're going to do.
I'm going to ring a bell.
And at that point, find an
upright, comfortable, erect
posture.
Close your eyes if you're
comfortable with it.
And just notice the
sensations of your breath.
This kind of
fundamental exercise
underlies all the things
we're going to talk about.
So just notice what it
feels like to breathe.
We're breathing all the
time, but how often do
we actually notice
what it feels like?
So if that's the air passing
in and out of your nostrils,
if that's the diaphragm
rising and falling,
just try to tune in
on that sensation.
And what's going to
happen, I guarantee
you, after 5 seconds
or 30 seconds,
is your mind's going to wander.
You're going to wonder
what's for lunch after this,
why is this guy talking to me,
why aren't we doing anything.
And here's the whole game.
When that moment happens, just
gently bring your attention
back to the breath.
It's just attentional training.
So just try to return
the attention back
to those physical sensations.
Let's try it for just a
short little bit here.
[BREATHES DEEPLY]
[RINGS BELL]
If the mind's wandered, just
gently bring the attention back
to the breath.
[BREATHES DEEPLY]
[RINGS BELL]
OK.
I hope that wasn't too painful.
Good.
A lot of people actually
find it's rather enjoyable.
The velocity of our
days are so intense,
taking just that
brief moment to pause
can be actually refreshing.
And now, before I get started,
just a quick show of hands,
how many of you are kind
of believers in this?
And how many of you have some
understandable skepticism?
How many of you have taken
Search Inside Yourself
and lead the meditation groups,
as I know some of us do?
And how many of you
are kind of skeptics?
So I want a show
of hands, 0 to 10.
0 is I think this is all hokum.
This is New Age bogus.
I'm here to ridicule you
during the Q&A. 10 being,
I'm leading Search
Inside Yourself.
Just give me a
quick show of hands.
What do I see.
I see 8s.
I see 2s.
Good.
We have some work to do.
3s.
All right.
Thank you.
So we have a range of
perspectives on mindfulness
and mindless in the workplace.
Well, whatever
mindfulness is, and we'll
talk a bit about
this, it is spreading
throughout the business
world, as I've discovered.
At Goldman Sachs,
they're teaching
meditation and mindfulness to
their traders, their investment
bankers.
And there's a board
member, Bill George,
who's actually espousing the
benefits of mindful leadership.
At this small tech company
you probably haven't heard of,
Facebook, they are
actually retooling
some of the algorithms,
trying to make
them more compassionate.
They have Compassion
Research Days.
And of course, you guys are
doing great work here as well.
At General Mills, big food
company in Minneapolis,
Minnesota, there's a meditation
room in every single building
on corporate campus.
That's pretty extraordinary
for the Midwest, I think.
It's not just the
business world.
In healthcare,
nurses and doctors
are finding that
mindfulness training makes
them more resilient during
these 12, longer hour shifts,
allowing them to be more
compassionate and more
attentive to their patients.
And patients, too, are
finding that mindfulness
and meditation, it might
not make the pain go away,
but it helps them suffer
just a little less.
They can manage
that pain better.
In schools, kids are meditating.
They're finding that it
actually improves test scores.
Studies are finding
that teachers
are finding that it
helps them actually
deal with these kids a bit
more, especially the ones who
aren't meditating, perhaps.
And in the military, the Army
and the Marines here in the US
are both using
mindfulness training,
not to make more
effective fighters, not
to make more accurate snipers,
but to help these guys
deal with whatever it was they
encountered on the battlefield
when they come home,
to help cope with PTSD
and some of the other things
they have to carry with them.
And even in sports, this
guy, he came very close
but didn't quite get it.
But for the last two
years, the Seahawks
have been incorporating
mindfulness training side
by side with their
weight training.
They say it's
almost as important
as the physical preparation,
is the mental preparation.
These guys are doing
it in the locker room.
They have a full-time
mindfulness coach on staff.
I was in Davos just in
January, and every day,
the World Economic
Forum actually
began with an hour of
mindfulness meditation, which I
thought was just extraordinary.
And I wrote a story about
it, "Amid the chattering
of the global elite,
a silent interlude."
And I guarantee you it was about
the only moment in this week
that people actually
shut up there.
And there, of course, is a
magazine, "Mindful Magazine,"
detailing all these stories.
So what is mindfulness?
Well, a common
definition is it's
paying attention in
a particular way,
on purpose, in the present
moment, and nonjudgmentally.
And I know that
sounds like a lot.
It's quite a mouthful.
But if you unpack it, I
think it's really just
about being right
here right now, not
getting lost in
ruminations about the past,
unpacking mistakes we
may have just made,
not getting stuck in
fantasies and preparations
for the future, but
actually just attending
to the present moment
right here, right now
instead of letting our minds
essentially carry us away.
Who's the guy that coined this?
It's Jon Kabat-Zinn.
He's a molecular
biologist from MIT.
And he's done more than
just about anyone else
in the last three decades or
so to popularize mindfulness.
He realized when he
was studying to be
a doctor, that in
fact, mindfulness
was helping him reduce his
stress, maybe alleviate
some pain he was having.
So he thought, what would happen
if I brought this to the place
where the most pain I know
is, which was hospitals.
So he started going to doctors.
And he said, bring me the
patients who you're just
not curing, the
ones who are just
in pain that will not go away.
And he developed a
system called Mindfulness
Based Stress Reduction, MBSR.
And what they found
was, again, it
didn't make the pain go away.
Of course, the physical
sensations were still there.
The neurons were still firing.
But the stress levels
of these patients
started to come down just
through that simple attentional
practice that we
practiced very briefly.
And again, how did he say you
have to cultivate mindfulness?
Well, unfortunately,
it's meditation.
And I know for a lot of
people, meditation's hard.
And I get it.
It's hard for me, too.
It's not the only way,
but Jon Kabat-Zinn
reemphasized over and over
that practice matters,
that simple attentional
training-- come on in.
Meditation is actually just a
tool to train our attention.
And when we train
our attention, we
can have more control over
how we respond to things.
Mindfulness meditation,
we did it briefly.
You set upright
comfortably, feel
the sensations of your breath,
notice what's happening.
And then, when your mind
wanders, just begin again.
That's the whole game.
And so again, let's just do
it for 30 seconds right now.
If you're eating, just
put your food down.
If you've got your
phone out, that's fine.
We're just going to sit for
just a few more seconds.
[BREATHES DEEPLY]
[RINGS BELL]
OK.
Again, not too painful, I hope.
That's a basic kind of sitting
or standing meditation.
And that's a common practice.
It's easy just to find
a comfortable posture
and try to focus on the breath.
But there are other
ways to do it.
And you can learn
about those at MBSR,
or I think Google even
has some classes here
that teach not just
sitting meditation--
because not everyone's able to
just sit still all the time--
but walking meditation, or
even things like the body scan,
where we bring that kind
of laser-pointed attention
to all the different
sensations of our body.
What happens when we start
to do this over time?
It doesn't happen immediately.
But over time, a lot of
people talk about the movement
from reaction to response.
So we're bombarded
with stimulus all day.
It can be an email.
It can be a sharp
remark from a colleague.
It can be the call to a meeting.
And so often, we just react.
We don't even take time
to pause and consider
what we're going to
do next, to consider
what an appropriate
response might be.
But mindfulness, that
training and attention,
it's shown over and over that
it gives us just a moment
to breathe, a moment
to pause, to find
that appropriate response
before we respond.
So to move from
reaction to response
can be totally valuable.
I find it every day.
Even before I pick
up the phone, I often
let it ring one or two times.
And the person is always
there after two rings.
But I've given myself
just a moment to calm down
and to get myself a
little more centered
and hopefully approach
it not with whatever
it was I was doing in my mind
when I pick up that phone,
but with a fresh mind.
Now, mindfulness is an
innate human quality,
I like to call it.
It's something that
we all possess.
It's something every culture
has touched on over the years,
every tradition.
But it's true.
I don't want to
hide the ball here.
Mindfulness as it's
being practiced today,
secular mindfulness, Mindfulness
Based Stress Reduction,
has its origins in
Buddhist practice.
The term mindfulness is kind of
sprinkled across the Buddhist
teachings like
stars in the night.
And Buddhist meditation
itself is largely
designed to cultivate an
experience of mindfulness.
But I can't emphasize enough,
over the last 30 years or so,
thanks largely to Jon Kabat-Zinn
and some of his peers,
it's become a purely
secular thing.
What we practice in
these boardrooms, what
Goldman Sachs is doing,
what you're doing here,
it is areligious.
It may have drawn
its inspiration
from Buddhism many
years ago, but it's
a purely secular practice.
You're not going to find
references to the sutras
when you go to Search
Inside Yourself.
And this secularization, this
essentially cultural migration,
which I think is just
a fascinating story,
is what's allowed big companies
to embrace mindfulness.
About 10 days ago, I had a
piece on the cover of the Sunday
Business Section of "The Times"
that profiled Mark Bertolini.
He's the CEO of Aetna.
It's a Fortune 100 company,
550-some-odd billion
in revenues, big healthcare
provider in Hartford,
Connecticut.
And Mark's just got
an amazing story.
About 10 years ago, he
had a skiing accident,
and it almost killed him.
His vertebrae were
cracked in five places.
The nerves were separated
out from his arm socket.
And they thought
not only might he
not live-- the
priest administered
last rites at the hospital.
But he was so debilitated
when he got back
that his colleagues
said, you should just
take early retirement.
You've risen high enough.
He wasn't quite CEO now.
He was Executive Vice President.
You've risen high
enough in this company.
Just take the package and work
on taking care of yourself.
But he was persistent.
So he tried
conventional therapies.
He tried OxyContin,
Fentanyl, all sorts of drugs.
None of them worked.
The pain just wouldn't go away.
Finally, he tried a
craniosacral therapy.
Then he tried yoga.
And these things started to make
a difference where the drugs
didn't.
He was able to eventually
get off the drugs.
And then he discovered
mindfulness meditation,
started practicing mindfulness.
And in the matter of
months, he suddenly kind of
had the bounce back in his step.
He was able to really
get past the drugs.
He had four surgeries, of
course, to repair the damage.
But he was able to come back to
work with really renewed vigor.
Eventually, just around
the financial crisis,
he became CEO, and he took over.
And at that moment, I think
he kind of had a choice.
He could have said, all right,
what do my investors, what
do my board members expect.
They expect me to kind of double
down, batten down the hatches,
get through this tough
period, and see it through.
And he did that on
the performance level.
Aetna's doing better now
than it was five years ago.
But he also said, listen.
This experience I've
had, it's transformed me.
It's given me new
insights into the way
that alternative therapies
can work to heal people.
And what are we in the
business of here at Aetna?
We're in the business
of providing healthcare.
So he said, let's
start a pilot program,
just with a few hundred
patients at first,
and offer yoga and
meditation to our employees.
He took this to the
Chief Medical Officer,
a guy named Lonny Reisman,
very serious clinician.
He said, I want to offer
mindfulness and meditation.
And Lonny said, heck, no.
Are you crazy?
I mean, just because you've done
it, you think we all should?
Calm down.
And Mark said, OK.
He appealed to the
clinician in Lonny.
He said, let's
measure the results.
We'll work with Duke University.
And self-reported stress
results are notoriously
kind of fungible,
so why don't we
measure heart rate variability.
Why don't we measure
cortisol levels?
And why don't we just
see what happens?
They did a 10-week pilot,
yoga and meditation
for about 500 employees.
Then they did all the results.
The self-reported stress,
perhaps unsurprisingly,
went down.
It's nice to take a break
in the middle of the workday
and maybe do a
little gentle yoga.
It's nice to maybe pause and
just quiet down as we did.
But then they checked the data.
And the biostatisticians, Mark
told me, they were floored.
Because all the numbers,
the heart rate variability,
the cortisol, they
all came down.
And so there was
real data that showed
actually the physiological
impact of this
was just as real as the
self-reported "I'm feeling
better at work."
something actually
seemed to be happening
in these people's bodies.
So they rolled it out.
They scaled this program with
the help of Duke University.
Rolled it out to thousands
and thousands of people.
They also rolled out a
mindful eating program,
which is perhaps
appropriate to talk about
while we're here at lunch.
And so they got people focusing
on not only what they were
eating, but when and
how and what else they
were doing when
they were eating,
and how much they were eating.
And they really brought
that fine-grained attention,
that mindfulness practice,
to the act of eating.
It's something you learn in
some mindfulness classes.
And they measured this
over several months.
And they found that actually,
in a sampling of overweight
and obese Aetna
employees who wanted
to try this intervention as a
potential weight loss therapy,
it worked.
Just by actually bringing more
mindfulness, more attention
to the act of eating, they found
that they were eating less,
they were eating
healthier, and they
were eating fewer times
throughout the day,
not snacking, just
compulsively eating.
And that, I just want to
offer, is a simple tip.
I know it's not easy.
I am fully guilty of
scarfing down soup at my desk
far too many times
during the workweek.
But when I find the willpower
essentially to pause
and actually enjoy a
meal, eat mindfully,
I find that I eat
less, I eat healthier,
and I frankly enjoy
my food a bit more.
So then an amazing
thing happened.
About a year after
Aetna had really
scaled these programs,
offered it all,
he was reviewing the 2012
financial performance
for the company.
And he noticed
something astounding.
In the midst of the
financial crisis,
healthcare costs at the
company had fallen 7.3%
in the full year after they
did the mindfulness and yoga
and prevention.
And by this time, it was
reaching tens of thousands
of employees.
That amounted to $9
million for Aetna.
And I asked Mark.
I said, are you saying that
yoga and meditation saved you
$9 million?
Is it that direct of a line?
He said no.
We were doing a couple
other wellness interventions
at the time.
We were doing more
health screening.
We had this weight
loss program going on.
But, he says, it
has to have helped.
There's nothing else we did.
And we were measuring it
on a per-employee basis.
So the fact that they
may have hired or fired
a few people, that wasn't
going to matter either.
And so they've
continued to do it.
And health care
costs now remain well
below what they were
on a per-employee basis
before they started
these interventions.
Then Mark, he said, OK.
It's working here.
13,000, about a third of
the company's workforce,
has now done it.
They've now started working
with other companies
to bring these programs.
And they're offering
it as a paid
service, part of their
broader wellness initiative.
So all a pretty extraordinary
story of how mindfulness,
yoga actually took hold at
one big Fortune 100 company.
And I thought that was kind
of the end of the story.
I had written all
this for my book.
The book was all done.
And then in January, I saw
an extraordinary headline.
Mark Bertolini had read this
book over the Christmas break.
He came back to
Aetna in January.
And he said, I'm
giving all my lowest
paid workers a 33% raise.
And for these workers
in Tallahassee
who were making $12 an
hour at a call center,
a 33% raise was huge.
He announced it at a
meeting down in Florida.
People started crying
in the audience.
And it was this
transformative moment.
He said, I was so moved by
the stories and the arguments
I read in "Capital
in the 21st Century,"
this treatise on inequality,
that I couldn't help but not
do this.
And when I saw Mark, I said, OK.
But are you saying your
meditation practice-- I mean,
is there any relation whatsoever
between yoga and meditation
and giving people a raise.
He said, listen.
It's not a direct
line of causation.
But mindfulness has made
me so much more aware
of what's going on in
my mind and my body,
and it's also made me more
aware of my impact as a CEO
and as a business leader,
that when I read this book
and I considered what was
going on with my employees,
I couldn't help but
not make this decision.
And now Aetna, true to form,
is working with the Peterson
Institute to help other
multinationals figure
out would it be actually
economical, might
it be a good thing, to
raise wages for some
of the lower paid workers.
And even in the last few weeks,
we've seen Walmart follow suit.
Why am I the person up here
telling you this story?
Well, just in brief,
I grew up here
in San Francisco,
beautiful Bay Area.
Looks pretty appealing
after this winter.
And I, as a teenager, was asking
all of life's big questions,
looking for answers, and
getting absolutely nowhere.
And then freshman
year of college,
I opened up a book
about Buddhism,
started reading
about mindfulness,
and suddenly something
started to make sense.
It said, there's
a way to get off
this hamster wheel of our mind.
There's a way to actually
be in the present moment
instead of constantly
thinking about the future
or dwelling in the past.
So I did what any parent
would hope their kid do.
I got on a one-way ticket to
India and moved to Bodh Gaya.
I spent my 21st birthday
in a Buddhist monastery,
where saffron robed monks woke
me up every morning at 4:00 AM.
There were peacocks
roaming the courtyard.
It was a pretty wild place.
And for about six
months, I stayed
in Bodh Gaya, which is the place
where the Buddha ostensibly
was enlightened.
That's the Bodhi temple.
That's the tree under
which he ostensibly sat
or at least a relative,
many generations removed
from the original, of course.
I studied with Zen masters.
I studied with
Tibetan rinpoches,
supposedly reincarnated.
And I studied with
this guy, Munindra-ji.
And Anagarika Munindra-ji
is a Bengali man.
He looks a little like
Gandhi, and weirdly, he
was a close friend of Gandhi.
But he was also one of
the great mindfulness
teachers of the 20th century.
He instructed a
generation of teachers
who then, in the mid '70s,
came back to the United States
and founded some of
the retreat centers
that would eventually kind
of give birth to this secular
mindfulness movement
today, teachers
like Jack Kornfield, Joseph
Goldstein, and Sharon Salzburg.
They founded Insight
Meditation Society.
And that's where Jon
Kabat-Zinn was in 1978
or '79, when he had that
epiphany, when he said, wait.
This might actually help me
reduce my personal stress.
What happens if I take
it to the hospital?
And I was really fortunate to
spend a fair amount of time
with Munindra-ji during some
of the later years of his life.
It was an honor.
And there I am sitting under
the Bodhi tree with Munindra.
There I am with a
Tibetan rinpoche.
And I think if I
had stayed in India,
this is what I would look like.
That's Yogi Mike.
He's been in Bodh Gaya
for a very long time.
I didn't stay in India.
I came back.
I'm now a reporter at
"The New York Times."
I was at the "Financial
Times" before that.
And I've continued to
practice meditation.
I still try to go on
retreat when I can,
harder now with an
11-month-old and a busy job.
But it's important.
It's important
for me to get back
to try to remember what it
was like over there in India.
But instead of retreat centers,
I've spent most of my time
in places like this,
"The New York Times"
newsroom, which is one
of the least mindful
places I know, full of screaming
editors, tight deadlines,
and angsty reporters.
And it was while
I was at the FT,
though, that I wrote an
article that actually got me
to this very stage right now.
It was called "The
Mind Business."
And what I had done at the FT,
I had recently profiled Zuck,
I had interviewed
Bernie Madoff in prison,
and I was at a loss
for a good story.
I desperately needed a good
story to sink my teeth into.
And I was kind of frustrated
that I didn't have one.
And then I was combing
the wires one day,
and I saw an article
that jumped out at me
like nothing else ever had.
It said, in
Minneapolis, Minnesota,
a company, General Mills,
was offering meditation
to its employees.
And I said, huh.
And for the first
time, I thought maybe
there was a way to bring these
two disparate parts of my life
together.
So I got on a plane, and I
went out to General Mills.
And this is, you
know, the company
that makes Haagen-Dazs
ice cream, and Cheerios,
and Hamburger Helper.
I didn't know what to expect.
I was a little skeptical.
Would what they were doing
be anything I recognized?
Would it resemble anything I
had practiced in the centers
that I'd been going to
for all these years?
I didn't know.
And then I showed up in this
conference room, 3 o'clock
on a Tuesday.
And this is several
years ago now.
And there was 60 or so-- maybe
not quite that many-- employees
all practicing
mindfulness meditation.
They were totally silent.
And the woman
leading them seemed
to know what she
was talking about.
This woman, Janice Marturano,
she was the Deputy General
Counsel at the time, very
senior lawyer at the company.
She worked on mergers
and acquisitions.
She did the Pillsbury
acquisition.
And in the midst of that
particular deal, a $10 billion
merger that she was fighting
to get through regulators
in Washington, both of
her parents passed away.
So this personal blow on
top of the stresses of work
just laid her out.
And she could barely
get back to work.
A friend suggested mindfulness.
She said, no way.
I'm a good Midwestern girl.
No, thank you.
A few weeks later, they
suggested it again.
She was at her wit's end.
She said, fine.
She got a plane,
went to Arizona,
and met Jon Kabat-Zinn.
And Jon Kabat-Zinn kind of
instructed her on mindfulness.
When he said, for
the first time,
we're going to sit in
silence for an hour,
she almost got up
and walked away.
And I don't blame her.
But five days later, after
kind of gradually becoming
immersed in this practice,
she didn't want to leave.
But she did.
She came back.
And one by one,
at General Mills,
people started to notice
that she was a bit changed.
She seemed to, again, have
maybe a little more bounce
in her step.
She was calm at meetings when
everyone else seemed frazzled.
And they said,
what are you doing.
What's different?
What drugs are you on?
And she said, I'm
practicing mindfulness.
If you're interested,
let me know.
I'm not pushing it on anyone.
Eventually, she had a quorum.
And they took a small retreat
up at the Fetzer Institute
in Minnesota.
And they loved it.
People came back, and
they said, we want more.
So it snowballed, just a
very organic, ground-up kind
of thing.
She felt relatively empowered.
But this wasn't coming
from the C-suite.
And so they started doing this
mindful leadership training
at General Mills.
Eventually, it really
started to scale.
There were more people
that she couldn't handle.
She brought in
other instructors.
And now, as with Aetna, there
are thousands of meditators
and a meditation room
in every building.
And Janice, she was
the one that taught
me that trick with the phone.
And she talks about
these purposeful pauses,
just taking brief moments
throughout the day
to interrupt our
reactive routines,
to stop what it is we think
we're just automatically
supposed to do and
instead just pause,
consider the appropriate
response, and then take action.
It's nothing too dramatic, but
it can make a big difference.
And it's probably
prevented me from getting
in a lot of hot water with
editors and other reporters
over the years.
And here are other
General Mills employees
taking a different kind
of purposeful pause.
I don't necessarily
advocate this
in the middle of a meeting.
"The Mind Business"
went viral inasmuch
as an FT article behind
a paywall can do.
Everyone wanted to know more.
Where could they
find information?
Who else was doing this?
What's this is all about?
And I didn't have the answers.
I was kind of blindsided
by the interest.
And it was at that point
that I realized maybe
I need to keep
working on this story.
So I got a book
deal, I went out,
and I set out on what I
think of as kind of a journey
into the contemplative
heart of the working world,
to the contemplative heart
of corporate America.
Again, didn't know what
I was going to find,
but was happily surprised.
All these companies and
more, in one way or another,
are bringing mindfulness to
bear on their decision-making.
Eileen Fisher, Patagonia,
Ford Motor Company,
Google-- thank you guys
for having me-- BlackRock,
more, Bank of America.
I mean, the list
goes on, and it's
growing every day, which
is just extraordinary.
One of the companies I came
across early in my reporting
was Green Mountain Coffee.
Not great coffee, but an
interesting and influential
CEO.
Guy's name was Bob Stiller.
And he maybe is actually
a likely candidate
for this stuff.
Before he took over
Green Mountain Coffee
and turned it into the
multi-billion dollar company
it is, he founded Easy
Wider Rolling Papers.
So you get a sense of where
this guy was coming from.
That's him in a picture
taken for "Forbes Magazine,"
meditating on a bag
of coffee beans.
And essentially, once
he was a billionaire,
he said, what the heck.
Let's roll out
meditation in the office.
Didn't know what
he would expect.
Brought it first to C-suite.
They all loved it.
They would just take brief
pauses, moment of silence
before they started a meeting.
Loved it.
Rolled it out then
to middle management,
to graphic designers, who said
it helped them focus better.
They were actually able
to stay in the zone,
doing their creative
work more effectively.
And then I love this.
About a year, two years into
this program, they said,
wait a sec.
It's great that we're
doing this for all
our C-suite executives
and our white collar,
middle management.
But we run dozens of factories
that employ thousands
of people around the country.
We have these blue collar
guys roasting these beans,
packing them in these
heavy bags and boxes,
driving our trucks delivering
this stuff all over the place.
What do we have to offer them?
So they worked with
a yoga teacher.
They brought over the Head of
Wellness from Ben & Jerry's.
And they developed a
mindful stretching routine
for their factory workers.
And so every day,
before these guys
start their 12-hour shifts,
they go into their locker room,
which was once kind of
this kind of rowdy place,
and they practice mindfulness.
And it's an extraordinary
sight to see,
these very hard-edged, tough--
northern Vermont is where
I was-- guys, bandannas on
their heads, Red Sox hats,
and all of a sudden, they just
take a few moments and practice
mindful stretching.
It's a sight to behold.
And I actually think that
there's a lesson here.
It's what some people called
your mindfulness zones.
They're just these physical
spaces in your workplace
that can be prompts
to remember to just do
a quick 30-minute practice.
For me, at times,
it's the elevator.
If I get on the elevator and
I'm lucky enough to be alone,
I actually just don't
look at my phone,
I don't worry about what's
going to happen when I get off
at the next floor.
I just try to check in with
my body, feel my breath,
notice what's happening.
Other people say
it's just a corridor.
And I'm sure you all have
your highly trafficked areas
in this building.
And I would invite you,
if you're interested,
just pick one and see
over the course of a week
if you can use it as a prompt
to remember to just put away
your phone, stop the incessant
yakking in our heads,
and just see how you're feeling.
Some good might come of it.
We'll see.
So what does all this get us?
Well, at Aetna, the
data started to come in.
It makes us less stressed.
That's why Jon Kabat-Zinn
focused on Mindfulness Based
Stress Reduction.
There's a study
with a big number--
no faith in the
methodology-- but it
said that it cost
businesses $300 billion
per year, by the World
Health Organization.
Again, no idea what that number
means, but I think the point
is accurate.
And I think we saw it
reflected in Aetna.
Stress is debilitating
in many ways.
It can reduce productivity.
It can make us vulnerable,
susceptible to illness.
And to the productivity
point, I forgot to mention it.
Aetna.
Another thing they noticed.
They noticed three
key metrics come down.
Stress levels decreased.
Perceived pain levels decreased.
Sleep quality improved.
And at Aetna, workers reported
to gain 62 additional minutes
per week of productive time.
And Aetna-- actually,
there's a methodology
I do believe in that they use
to come up with this number.
And they say that that
actually amounted,
they believe, to $3,000
per year per employee.
So again, productivity
perhaps as well.
And that's the focus.
Meditation seems to
improve our focus.
A nice way to think about
it is like going to the gym,
to use the Seahawks analogy.
Just as going and
lifting weights
kind of improves the muscles in
our biceps perhaps, meditation,
that training, that
attentional training,
bringing our attention
back to the breath
over and over, essentially
training for our minds.
There's a great study that
shows meditation actually
reduces task switching.
So they put office
workers, give them
a ton of tasks to complete
in a finite amount of time.
And non-meditators
switch between tasks
every three, five
seconds, I mean,
just scrambling to
get things done.
The meditators,
instead, focused on one,
did it not entirely
to its completion.
But they actually stayed on each
action item for a longer time.
And the results were
pretty dramatic.
Mindfulness also seems
to improve our health.
Aetna again showed us this.
And there are other
studies that show
mindfulness meditation
can actually
boost the immune system.
In an incredible study, they
took psoriasis patients,
gave them the traditional
UV lightbox therapy.
And one group kind of did
the traditional therapy.
And in the other, gave them
the traditional therapy,
but also gave them mindfulness
meditation instructions
over the course of several
weeks as they were doing this.
And they healed faster.
Amazing.
Mind over matter, perhaps.
In any case, leading
to healthier employees.
Now all this research
into our brains and bodies
has been accompanied over
the last several decades
by new insights
into what happens
in the brains of meditators.
For a long time, people
thought about the brains
as essentially
fixed, static items.
Once they evolved, they
were kind of mature.
Then they slowly degraded.
Recently, though, we found out
that our brains are actually
plastic.
They're malleable.
This term
neuroplasticity suggests
that whatever we put
into our brains, whatever
stimulus we present
ourselves with,
our brains become more
accustomed to that.
They're very flexible actually.
And there are studies
that now show this.
In the minds of meditators,
in the prefrontal cortex--
that's the area associated
with higher order processing.
It's evolutionarily
the newest part
of our brain, kind of
the part of our brain
that makes us very human.
In the minds of
meditators, there's
actually more gray matter.
And in another study that's
been repeated many times,
they show that the amygdala,
this almond-shaped region
near the center of our brains,
controls our stress reaction,
releases stress hormones.
It's actually less reactive.
There's less cortisol
pumping through the amygdala
in the minds of meditators.
I had my own brain studied.
This isn't my brain.
But this shows the
increasing gray matter
in the prefrontal cortex.
There I am at Yale
getting my brain scanned.
And this is what they found.
It's not perfect.
Mindfulness is
definitely no cure-all.
So healthier, less stressed,
maybe even a little happier,
maybe a little more productive.
I'd like to offer one more thing
that mindfulness maybe can do.
This is Tim Ryan.
He's a congressman, represents
Ohio's 13th district.
He's a Catholic high school
quarterback from Ohio.
Perhaps not your most likely
advocate for mindfulness.
But in recent years,
that's just what
he's become on Capitol Hill.
He leads the Quiet Time Caucus.
You may not have heard of it.
And he wrote a book called
"A Mindful Nation," where
he really looks at how
to bring mindfulness
to our schools and our
veterans, in particular,
two of his passions.
I said, Jim, what has
this done for you overall.
I mean, I get maybe it's
helped you be less stressed.
But what's the
impact on your work?
I mean, you still
have to be out there
representing your constituents.
You still have to be
dealing with everyone
on the other side of the aisle.
He said, mindfulness
has made me slow down.
You actually slow down
enough to pay attention
to someone other than yourself.
It's made me a little more
sympathetic, empathetic,
and compassionate.
And I think this is
radical, because so often we
think about mindfulness
as something
like, I'm doing to myself
to make me perform better.
But Tim's actually saying it's
not about that in the end.
It's about how he can
help other people.
And we saw with
that Aetna as well.
And we see it in the
work of Eileen Fisher.
Eileen developed her own very
successful clothing company.
And she ran a very conventional,
if private, company
for many years.
And it was only
several years ago
that she began
practicing mindfulness.
First yoga, then began
mindfulness meditation.
And initially-- the story
may be familiar now.
She started kind of with
her close associates.
She reorganized the
way they did meetings.
Instead of her sitting at the
head of a conference table,
she got round tables
so-- she calls it
the circle way, trying to
reduce some of the hierarchy,
value other people's
opinions more.
She started offering new
health and wellness initiatives
for her employees.
And then she had that
same moment that Mark had,
the same moment that Bob
Stiller at Green Mountain had.
She said, what about the
people at the very other end
of my workflow?
What about the people in
China in the factories
that make all this clothing?
What do we do for them?
She said, it's probably
not practical to introduce
meditation in mainland China.
But how else can I help?
So she improved healthcare
for her workers there.
She improved working conditions.
She started using more
sustainable products,
less toxic dyes.
And then she started an
entrepreneurship program
for her Chinese workers,
actually giving them
the training to start their
own businesses so they could
actually get out
of her factories
and start doing their own work.
So I love this.
It's another example of kind
of a top-down initiative, how
an empowered leader
said, I'm going
to start changing
the way we work here.
And I'd like to just frame it.
There's bottom-up and top-down.
Eileen Fisher, Mark
Bertolini, kind
of this top-down model
as CEO, saying, here's
how we're going to
do it, and it scales.
And then there's bottom-up.
And I think you guys are
kind of a borderline.
I know Meng, who got
the ball rolling here,
he's one of the early employees.
But he really just
started this himself.
It wasn't as if Eric or
Larry or Sergey said,
you're all going
to meditate now.
It was an organic thing that
started very much like what
happened to General Mills.
And so people often ask me, how
do I bring mindfulness to work.
Well, there's a lot
of ways to do it.
And how do we practice?
Well, I hope I gave
you a couple tips.
There's just brief meditation
. practice we did earlier.
There's mindful eating.
You can take that
purposeful pause
before picking up the phone.
Or you can find
your kind of space
in the office that's maybe
a cue, a reminder just
to practice.
And so I hope that's
given you kind
of a flavor for how mindfulness
is out there in the world
transforming big businesses,
small businesses.
And now I'm going to
potentially imperil myself.
But I'm going to ask again.
Quick show of hands, show
me again, skeptics 0,
still think it's absolute hokum.
10 is you're signing
up with [INAUDIBLE]
and doing the 2 o'clock
meditation today.
So if I could just
again, 0 to 10?
Any movement?
I think I turned a 3
to like a 4 and 1/2.
That's all I ask.
I got a 2 to a five.
My work here is done.
Mindfulness is no panacea.
It maybe can make
us less stressed,
maybe a bit healthier, maybe
a bit more focused, maybe even
kinder, maybe a bit more
socially responsible.
But it's not going to make
a bad boss behave better.
And it's not going
to give us a raise
overnight just because
we start sitting.
But it's out there.
It's working.
It's spreading.
Anderson Cooper did
it on "60 Minutes."
I hear he's a committed
meditator now.
"Time" magazine featured it.
Recent companies that
have embraced this
are Intel and Adobe.
And I hope that gives you a
flavor for just how mindfulness
is spreading through
the working world
and how it might offer
us a new way to work.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
If there are questions, people
can maybe find their way
to one of the mics.
If there aren't
any questions, I'm
going to make us
all meditate more.
Yeah.
Hi, how are you?
AUDIENCE: Good.
My name is Matt.
I recently started
mindfulness meditation.
I've been very pleased so far.
My question for you is, is
there a place for mindlessness
in the day to day?
I know mindfulness is kind of
this-- or some people frame
it as this superior
state of being.
But I guess, is there a
place from alternating
between the two, or
should one always try
to be mindful whenever possible?
Because I feel like,
at least for me,
it's kind of
difficult to maintain
this always mindful state.
DAVID GELLES: It's
a great question,
and it's absolutely hard.
And I think it's not
realistic to expect
ourselves to be always mindful.
I guess what I'd say is
I would try not to create
such a polarization and such a
dichotomy between mindfulness
as this kind of paradigm
of healthy living,
and whatever is not mindfulness
as some reckless state.
I think the nature of
the mind is to wander.
And the nature of the mind is
to be intrigued by stimulus
and to want to check
our smartphones.
And I'm not suggesting that
we stop doing any of that.
I think what
mindfulness meditators
advocate is that by training our
attention, by giving ourselves
the ability, the potential,
the willpower, essentially,
to bring ourselves back to
the present moment in very
deliberate ways, good things
can happen in those moments.
So I love the
question, and I think--
I want to consider a more
fulsome answer ultimately.
But I guess I would start
by trying not to perpetuate
this myth that
mindfulness is somehow
this elevated
state that suggests
every other way of
being is inferior.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I actually-- I read your
article in "The Times" Business
section about Aetna.
And there were several
comments by skeptics.
And my recollection is
that they were actually
people in the
scientific community
and the medical community.
And I always-- I see that a lot
in articles about mindfulness.
And I was just wondering,
is that sort of an attempt
to sort of balance
being too fervent
and include the skeptical view.
Because I do notice that
trend in almost every article
I read about mindfulness.
DAVID GELLES: Yeah.
No, it's a great question.
And here we're just
talking more about kind
of the editorial practices
of "The New York Times."
But I'll see what I can
do without getting myself
in trouble.
So in the book, I
include a whole chapter
on what people are dubbing
McMindfulness, which
is essentially the critics.
They say it's not
based in science.
It's denaturing a
robust tradition.
And there's all sorts of reasons
why we shouldn't be doing this.
And in the article, the
excerpt of the article,
the Aetna stuff didn't
quite fit neatly with that.
So my editor, she
actually said, we
need some more skeptical
voices in here.
So I did a few things.
One, I actually
pulled some material
from that portion of
my book, which I think
is a valid kind of
path of inquiry.
I think it's important
to address the skeptics,
even if to wholehandedly
dismiss them.
And so I did that.
And then I also kind
of went a bit further.
Given that it's "The Times"
and we have high editorial
standards that some
people occasionally
accuse us of false subjectivity,
it was important for us
to actually get in there
and give some voice to them.
But even then, I think
you'll find in the article,
I couldn't find
anyone who said, it's
absolutely irresponsible for
businesses to be doing this.
Some people said the
science is very early.
And I think that's true.
I mean, we're kind of in
the first inning of all
this research and exploration.
But I still have
yet to find someone
who says it's actually
harmful to introduce
these things in the workplace.
So I hope that helps.
Yeah.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Amy.
Thanks for coming today.
My question is what
do you think is
lost in the secularization
of mindfulness.
I started in a
Shambala tradition,
and I found that the philosophy
was-- like, I almost liked
that part better than sitting.
And as someone who's
studied in probably
more of a spiritual
tradition, what
do you think about the
loss of all that philosophy
in taking it to
corporate America?
DAVID GELLES: Right.
It's a great question.
I'm actually-- before
I got on stage here,
I was having some angstiness
because I'm in the midst
of a heated debate on email with
a guy who's-- he's come after
me.
And he really thinks that
offering and promoting
secular mindfulness
can actually do harm,
and it actually is a way of
reinforcing the self instead
of kind of breaking
down the self,
as the origins of these
traditions would suggest we do.
And what I say to
that is, I don't
think anything's
getting lost, because I
think this is something other
than the Shambala tradition.
And this is something
other than the Buddhism
that I studied in India.
And this is something
other than what
this guy is expecting of me.
And can this, can
mindfulness, can
secular mindfulness essentially
be a first step on a longer
journey?
Sure.
But I'm not here trying
to offer a Trojan
horse to Buddhist meditation.
I don't think that's
what this is about.
Instead, what I think
is-- mindfulness
can help in all sorts
of very practical ways.
And if it can make
people a little less
stressed and a little
healthier and a little kinder,
and if it can reduce
suffering on the margins
and make businesses behave
a bit more responsibly,
I don't see how we
can argue with that.
And no one I've found is
presenting secular mindfulness
as essentially kind of
traditional Buddhism
in disguise.
And I guess that's where
I would take umbrage with.
This notion that these are
exactly the same things,
I think, is how we
start to get in trouble.
Instead, I recognize that
they're really robust,
really rich, and
wonderful traditions,
and that secular mindfulness,
Mindfulness Based Stress
Reduction, what's being
practiced here and Goldman
Sachs, it may have originally
taken its inspiration from some
of these practices,
but I don't think
it's trying to accomplish
the same goals either.
But if it can, again, help
on the margins, that's
a good thing, I'd say.
I hope that helps.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thanks.
DAVID GELLES: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You sort of lumped in yoga
together with meditation.
And I had a question
specifically about that.
I completely buy that yoga
works and that meditation works.
But the reason it
works, in my mind,
is because yoga, for example,
is a form of exercise.
Is there any study
that compares yoga
versus more traditional
forms of exercise
and what's more effective there?
DAVID GELLES: I don't know
the answer to that question,
but you're right to
call me out on kind
of lumping things together.
What happens here--
mindfulness becomes
kind of a very vague term.
And in fact, I have
a whole passage
in the book where I
kind of try to come
to terms with what it is
we're actually talking about.
I will say all the
studies I pointed
to and all the research
that I include in my book
is mostly about Mindfulness
Based Stress Reduction or kind
of pure mindfulness
attentional training,
what we practiced earlier on.
Where yoga comes in--
it's often essentially--
it's how people find
out about mindfulness.
It's how both Mark and
Eileen Fisher, for example,
came to the practice.
And at Aetna, in some of the
studies, in some of the data
they did, they lumped together
the results from both yoga
and meditation practice.
But I try to be
pretty deliberate
about differentiating
between the two.
Nonetheless, for kind
of a lay audience,
it's often easy and
kind of helpful to group
these complementary practices,
as they're known, together.
I don't know the answer
to the yoga question.
There's actually a
great book by a guy
named Bill Broad about yoga.
He's a "New York
Times" reporter.
I see people wandering out.
I don't have a clock.
So maybe we'll take
one more question.
But I hope that helps.
I can give you name of that book
after the talk if that helps.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thank you for coming.
I had a question specifically
about the meditation part.
Once you decide to set aside
that time, what have you found
is effective for not
actually just continuing
those practices of either
dwelling on the past
or just worrying
about the future
and just carrying that same
behavior into that time
that you've carved out.
So are there recommended phrases
you're supposed to meditate on?
Or how do you recommend not
just doing the same thing,
but just sitting down
in a quieter space.
DAVID GELLES: Yeah.
It's hard, no doubt about.
Mindfulness meditation
is, I should add,
one of a variety of
meditative techniques.
There's transcendental
meditation.
There's mantra meditations.
So mindfulness meditation
doesn't necessarily
use any phrases.
Instead, the goal,
essentially, the practice
is just finding those moments,
essentially remembering.
And actually, that's one
Sanskrit interpretation
of the word.
The Sanskrit word
for mindfulness
is actually remembering--
so remembering
to come back to the present
moment over and over and over.
I wish I had a shortcut,
but what I would say
is it doesn't have to
be five minutes or 30
minutes every day for an
extended period, amount
of time.
I was talking to
[INAUDIBLE] earlier.
It's the short moments many
times throughout the day--
can be just as impactful
as a month-long retreat,
for example.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
DAVID GELLES: Yeah.
Thank you all so much.
You guys have made my day.
Thank you.